all right I think we'll start hi I am
Alan I'm from Norway and I'm here to
talk to you today about modern web
application security bugs so a few words
about me first I work for a small
consulting company in Oslo and I usually
work as a developer but I also do
security stuff so I do security testing
I do security architecture and I've also
started doing quite a lot of bug bounty
hunting as you can see I also build some
open-source security tools and I'm also
head of the OS Norway chapter out of
Norway and you have my Twitter handle
there as well if you want to ask me
questions later or during your talk or
whatever just raise your hand if you if
you have any questions during your talk
the OS top-10 has been out for quite a
few years and one of the the sad things
about the OS top-10 is that we've seen
the same bugs appear over and over and
over again since this is one of the
first ones came came out but as I
started to look into all of these bug
bounty programs and looking through what
was happening in these bug bounty
programs I could see a lot of new types
of bugs that were appearing that I that
didn't really get any focus because a
lot of people are just focusing on the
top ten so we had a new version of the
top ten come out in 2017 and on this
list were two new bugs or two three
actually but two of them were kind of
bugs in the second the last one is more
of a process thing but we had XML
external entities and in security
sterilization come in and these are
things that we've seen in these bug
bounty programs for a long time so what
I'm going to do in this talk is I'm
gonna go through I'm gonna start at some
of the new stuff in your sub ten and
then I'm gonna move outside at your top
ten and explain some of these bugs and
I'm either really brave or really stupid
because all the things I'm going to show
you is mostly demo based and I don't
have video backup because I don't
believe in that i I'm demo or die so
that they better work so if we go to the
bug bounty programs we'll see we see a
lot of the same things this is statistic
from bugcrowd
and we see a lot of the same things like
we see in the OS top-10 like cross-site
scripting is fairly dominant we have
stored cross-site scripting and
reflected cross-site scripting here and
we have
some other things like server-side
injection and and then a big pile of
father over there if we go to to hacker
one instead and their report will we'll
see that at the top here it's a bit hard
to read but it's also cross site
scripting that's the top one and then we
have information disclosure as the
second one and we can see they've also
divided this into industries so we can
see the transportation for instance over
here they have a big problem with
cross-site scripting one of the things
that I've really had a lot of help from
when we're learning about these bugs is
is to read reports coming out of these
bug bounty programs so this is a twitter
account called disclosed edge one which
will tweet out any new report that comes
out from from from hacker one and in
these reports you can actually also
search them or look them up on hacker
one they have this list as well but on
each of these reports you can go in and
you can find what was the bug about and
often they still share a lot of details
about how the bag was found etc this is
one of my bugs that I found in in the
library called Sam Levi which had an XML
signature wrapping Bone ability in it
I'll show you some of these reports
throughout this session so you can see
some examples of the things I'm talking
about so the first thing we'll start
talking about is XML and I mentioned XML
external entities and so let's go jump
straight into the demo so I have this
really simple API the top box here is
the request that I'm sending and the
bottom box down here is the response I'm
getting back from the server and this is
actually happening so I'm not just I'm
not faking it it's actually being sent
to the server and I get something back
so you can see if I click this multiple
times the only thing that's changing is
basically this ID field in the center
here I can also get the data back not
that interesting but now we're moving
into the XML external entity attack so
what I'm doing in this case is I'm
defining a new entity called content and
the content of this entity is going to
be the contents of this file called EDC
password
and then I'm gonna use this new entity
down here so let's see what happens it
grabs the contents of the file and it
pushes it into the XML and that's stored
in the database so now instead of a
simple name or something like that it
grabs the content of the file pushes it
in and because this is a this back-end
is a Java I can do more than that I
don't actually have to have the file
prefix there I can just remove that it
still works
but I could also just do a dot if I just
do a dot is gonna list all the files in
the current directory that the
application is running and I see there's
a file here that looks interesting
called passwords txt let's grab that and
it was the password was then Summer 2018
these kinds of passwords have been
mentioned many times in security gate
talks lately because people tend to
switch passwords in this pattern where
they add the year as a prefix so this
was the the base version of this we can
list file so we can grab files we can
steal stuff off the server now the next
part we have what's called Nexus LT and
then XSLT it lets us take an XML and
then transform that XML into something
else in this case I'm transforming an
XML into HTML so you can see down here
now I have an HTML I have body and I
have a table and I just took the values
from one of the previous messages that I
sent in and just converted it to it to
HTML using this XSLT but that's not all
that interesting but of course I can I
can use this because XSLT provides a lot
of features so if I can provide my own
XSLT then I can actually start to query
the system about things so in this case
I'm going to ask it what version of XSLT
is here so you can see here it says this
was version 2.0 this is the vendor of
this XSLT transformer so you get a lot
of information that's just leaked back
because I can I can do this there's also
an interesting property call or a
function actually called document so
with document I can take an file an XML
file that sits on the server and
include that in the XML so much like the
xxe that I just showed you but in this
case it has to be an XML file because if
not it wouldn't be able to parse it so
in this case I'm stealing a file called
pom.xml which is basically the
deployment descriptor for a Java app it
will contain all the dependencies so if
we if we scroll down here we can see
that it lists out all the dependencies
that this application is using of course
I could also do xxe in the XSLT because
the XSLT is also an XML so in this case
I'm just doing the exact same thing as I
did in the first example just dealing
the contents of this file it doesn't
have it there in in XSLT version 2 it
also provides a new function called own
parsed text and in this case it doesn't
have to be in XML anymore it doesn't
have to be valid XML anymore so I can
steal any file off the server I can just
do like this
and again I'm stealing the same file
just as an example I could also do
lookups across the network so now I have
I I can I can start to do HTTP queries
for instance from the XML parser so the
XML parser will go and look up this URL
that's here and this if I just open it
will see that what's behind this
internal you your I that I can't reach
from the outside is actually an elastic
search instance that's supposed to be
hidden but I can reach it because I'm
using this function abusing this
functionality basically to get stuff
that's that I'm not supposed to be able
to get sometimes when we're abusing and
xxe vulnerability we can't see the end
result coming back to us because maybe
it fails like it fails to parse it or it
doesn't really show a show was the XML
that did it it got from from the parsing
but in this case we can use something
called blind xxe so this is a bit a bit
more difficult to explain I'm just going
to show you first and I'm going to Spain
what happens afterwards so first I'm
going to set up a server that basically
gives back a file if if the parser tries
to go to my server it's going to get
this file that contains the data that
you see there
and what it's going to do it's going to
grab the contents of this passwords txt
file it's gonna send that back to me on
an HTTP request so if you see what's
happened when I click the send button it
first there's first a get request that
comes and gets this this file this yet
ext DTD file that's on top and then
there's a new request coming in and says
steal and then we see the password once
again yeah we see the password Summer
2018 here so to briefly explain what's
going on so just gonna close this one
what we're doing here is first we're
we're defining a parameter called data
and the contents of data is going to be
the contents of a file in this case it
is a shadow in in the next line here
we're defining a new parameter which
we're going to grab from my attacker
server so we're going to grab this DTD
that we see at the bottom here this DTD
it it contains a new entity called
external entity which contains this
stuff which basically at some point will
try to get something from my server so
this is where the data is leaked so it
loads the the DTD it adds all these
things down here and it ends up sending
the data back as a new get request
towards the end it's a bit more
difficult than the other ones where we
could just see the data coming back
immediately but it's also super scary
because this parser might be way down in
the stack somewhere where we can't even
reach it but suddenly it starts to ping
us back so this is an example from
hacker 1 in this case the the program is
run by Twitter the severity of this xxe
report was scored as a medium 5.3 but
the bounty the guy who found this got
was $10,000 for it so it's quite quite a
big sum of money because of course this
is a really serious issue if you can
steal any file off the server you could
steal things like SSH keys or other
passwords or things like that so it
might end up giving you access to the
server
so how do we stop it well there are a
few alternatives we could disable DTD
support so you can't define these
entities at the top of the xml so that's
the first thing we want to do some
frameworks have this feature called
secure XML parsing which will basically
do the same thing and then we can also
disable external entities there are a
lot of different ways if we go to the OS
XML external entity prevention cheat
sheet we'll see a lot of examples on how
to do this
luckily for dotnet developers xxe has
been disabled since version 4.5.2 so
this is quite a long time ago but yet we
still see developers re-enabling it
because they need some feature for some
reason in Java it's just disappointing
there are so many parsers that are still
vulnerable to this so you have to make
sure that you secure it I would actually
recommend that if you if you have an XML
parser try it out at a unit test so
you're sure that it's never reintroduce
later at some point so that was xxe
we're moving on to the next bit so we're
moving on to the insecurities
serialization bit there was also an EOS
top 10 and serialization is something
we're doing a lot
we are serializing objects into json or
xml or some kind of binary format to
pass it across the wire just storing in
database and things like that
these serialization is of course the
opposite we take the serialized object
and then we get it converted back into a
format or or an object that we we have
on the server this is used in all kinds
of places it's used in in IPC stuff it's
used in in all kinds of api's it's used
for caching it's used for shared caches
it's used for databases and all kinds of
things where we're passing objects back
and forth over the wire so we can
imagine it looked some looks something
like this so we have some kind of
adjacent writer class that's gonna
there's gonna take an object and then
it's going to serialize it for us into
JSON and then at some point later we're
gonna read it back in and we're gonna
specify the class that it's supposed to
create and we're gonna read stuff in and
just create a new object and this is
fine if we have the top object here this
is fine
like we have a class of person this
class has a name and it has a
constructor that takes a name and just
basically creates
an object that doesn't do anything other
than hold a tiny piece of data if we
look up the second class here though if
we were ever able to instantiate that
class from an API call this would
actually run a file because it does work
in the constructor and this might be a
utility that we have somewhere something
that we're not supposed to use from the
API but sometimes we're able to
instantiate those objects from the API
regardless so some of these frameworks
JSON frameworks or XML frameworks they
allow us to specify the type that we
want to get back so maybe the API is
supposed to take in a person but in this
case we have this dollar type thing
where we can specify well I actually
want this runner class instead of so I
want this class up here I don't want the
person object I wanted to instantiate
this type of object instead and if if
this feature is enabled in the framework
is it's going to start this class and
it's going to run the code same thing
here for XML we have this type parameter
it might be called something else but
you'll see it because you'll see like
package names and things and maybe even
like which DLL it's supposed to be in
and this would again allow us to
instantiate an object that we're not
supposed to be able to create from the
API usually these things are a bit more
complicated than this so this is one
example from from dotnet from the
presentation framework so in this case
you can see the dollar type and we're
creating an object data provider and
within this object data provider we're
creating a process and we're taking this
process and we're adding some some
parameters to a method and then we're
invoking that method so usually we have
to chain a few objects to get where we
want to be so we because of course as an
attacker we want to be able to run code
on the server so here is an example from
spring and in this case instead of
specifying the type like a parameter
we're instead and since you instead
using something called the dynamic proxy
and we're saying this is the interface
of the class that you're going to create
but the class itself is going to be
completely different so this case is
just going to do a ping so if I send
this it seems to fail
I'm getting like a 500 server error back
man it didn't work right but if we if we
look a bit further at this message we
can see all the way over here it says
class cast exception and then there's a
UNIX process at the end so it actually
did create a process it did actually run
ping but it wasn't able to convert that
into a contract so that's why it fell
but it actually did run what we're
supposed to run so but I mean ping
that's not all that interesting what if
we could get access to the server
instead so let's try that so what I'm
going to do in this case is I'm going to
run bash and I'm gonna give it a command
that is going to run so it's going I'm
gonna create an interactive bash shell
it I'm gonna send that to dev TCP a
hostname and a port so it's actually
gonna open a connection outwards toward
my attacker server and it's gonna create
a remote pass shell towards my server
but for that to work
I would first have to set up something
that listens on that port so I'm just
going to do that really easy using
netcat I'm gonna listen on for it 1 3 3
7 and then when I hit the send button
you see there's a new prompt that occurs
appeared here it says root on contacts
hackable victim so now I can actually
run commands here I can do LS I can
browse around the filesystem I have full
control over this server so I've just
hacked into it by using this realization
attack and then gotten a shell back to
me this is pretty scary here is an
example from hacker 1 this was in
Starbucks Starbucks program and someone
found a remote this realization
vulnerability in one of their systems
they had something called a JBoss mq
this is a message queue and this this
one was vulnerable to 2d civilization
attacks things that can happen with
these types of attacks like a lot of the
the the documentation and and blog posts
around the digitalization attacks have
been focused around things that are
are across of a specific specific
framework for instance like the
presentation framework that I just
showed you but what if someone could
instantiate bad utilities that we have
what if they could instantiate more than
one singleton of a class we expect to be
a singleton what if they could instantly
eight this util method the runner man or
the runner from class that we had what
if they could do things that were not
they're not supposed to be able to do so
we might have even though our frameworks
might not be vulnerable we might have
classes that are dangerous in our code
base and an attacker might be able to
instantiate those those object if he
knows what he's doing and of course this
can lead to all kinds of stuff this can
lead to denial of service because we
might be able to shut down the server we
could manipulate the state in the
session and things like that we could
compromise the integrity of the system
or we could even as I shown you get
remote code execution so the underlying
cause is usually that the attacker is
somehow able to specify the type so the
class that's supposed to be instantiated
it's is in the attackers the attacker is
able to to specify that somehow and then
get that object instantiated and the way
that we can stop this is first of all we
should keep our frameworks up-to-date
I've put that at the lower one because
it's but but it's it's kind of the most
important one because we a lot of these
things are being patched in frameworks
but we also want to limit this
realization to specific packages or
specific namespaces where we have our
API contracts we we want them to have
certain annotations for them to be able
to be instantiated by the the D
civilization framework things like that
and if we can we should really disable
specification of types like in in Jason
net it's disabled by default but you
might be able to turn it back on if you
need it but it might be dangerous so the
next one is something called template
injection this wasn't in the ORS top ten
and it's not listed as a specific thing
but then the top thing in our scope ten
is injection which covers a lot of stuff
when people think about injection they
usually think about Sigma injection
this is something quite different so we
have these templating frameworks where
we're using these fragments and we're
creating HTML in some way this these
this might be something we do on the
server side with something like racer
but it might also be something that
we're doing on the client-side using
components from react or angular or view
or something like that so we we have
these templates these templates are used
to create HTML and we kind of combine
these things and and and this simplifies
our architecture of course but it might
also be a bit dangerous so at least some
of the the first types of templating
frameworks they were quite the
implementation was really basic like so
if you had a template looking something
like this what would actually happen is
the it would parse this and it would run
something like this so it sees okay
there's an h1 and then and then there's
like these curly braces that's signifies
that here I'm going to run some code so
it splits it out into two strings and
then it runs eval on the thing in the
center with mark which might be okay I
mean this is a template provided by us
as a developer but it might also be
dangerous if we combine these things in
the wrong order so here's an example we
have a variable called title which
contains hello we have a simple template
the same template that I just showed you
where we have title as a variable and
then of course when we invoke the render
function of the template templating
framework it's gonna render h1 hello
perfect
but sometimes we we want to take a few
templates and kind of combine them into
a larger page because we want me well
might want to reuse some component of
the page in many different places so we
might render one thing in one part of
the code and we take the output of that
and we shove it in to another template
further down the line and we end up with
something like this and the thing is as
a developer this works perfectly so we
have title is slow and bodies world and
after rendering the first bit it's gonna
be h1 hello h1 and then we put it in the
second one and we render that and it's
gonna be hello world just like we expect
it but there's an issue here what if the
variable in the
first template contained a new template
so what if it contained instead of hello
it contained two times two inside curly
braces in this case it would render the
first template it will come back out as
a new template so you can see and in in
this line here we actually have a new
template which is the contents of the
variable coming from the end user and
then the end result is we're gonna
actually eval the stuff that's inside
here coming from the end user and we get
four here instead
but seeing code like this is boring so
let's do a demo I have this simple
application I can send in a I have a URL
parameter called name and I'm gonna send
in my name and what you see here at the
top is the rendered HTML and at the
bottom you see the source code of this
rendered HTML so in this case it just
says hello Alain and then you can see
the same thing down here it says hello
Ellen now what happens if I instead of
typing my name I typed two times 3 that
says hello six instead and it says hello
six down here as well so in this case we
have a template injection so I can
provide a template either or as a part
of the URL or as a post parameter that's
stored in in database or whatever and
it's going to be rendered on the server
side so I basically can run code on the
server so this is in this system that's
running this is using a templating
framework called twig so if I do
underscore self it's going to fail and
it's gonna actually reveal what type it
is because we're gonna say twig
environment here and it's a twig
template of hair and it fails but now I
know it's twig so now I can start to
mess around with it and I'm gonna do the
exact same thing as I did with the
insecurity sterilization I'm gonna use a
vulnerability that exists in twig which
is I can define a filter called x'q and
this filter is going to call the
function called ID or a a system utility
called ID so it's going to xx
ID which basically means it's going to
run
the ID command on the server and is
gonna print out whatever was there so in
this case it says well this application
is obviously running as dub dub dub data
but instead of running ID I'm gonna run
this bin bash see blah blah blah and and
just do the exact same thing as I did
with the insecurity sterilization so I'm
gonna set up a new listener like this
and I'm gonna send it in and as you can
see I now have a shell here on this
server and I'm not logged in as dub dub
dub - data and I can run commands just
as I did in the previous one now this
was server-side templating section so
you could see when when I just had two
times three it would come back as six
down here but what what about client
side so we have templating frameworks on
the client side as well things like
angular for instance so in this case I'm
going to send send this but I'm not
going to render it wrong on the on the
server side I'm gonna render it just as
a normal template so if you look down
here you see it still says two times
three down there but as the rendered
HTML it says six so obviously
something's now broken between the lower
one and the upper one so the rendered
HTML show is something different than
what's what's down there and the reason
is of course that there is angular is
being invoked there an angular sees this
two times three template down there and
it takes a I know I know this this is an
angular template I'm going to execute it
and we get hence we get the six of
course if we're thinking now we could do
cross-site scripting so instead of
instead of doing two times three we
could do alert one instead just like a
normal cross site scripting example
unfortunately in this case that wouldn't
work because in the this version of
angular 1.0.8 it had a sandbox so it
said you're not supposed to be able to
invoke a specific set of API from
templates but it also had a
vulnerability that allows you to get
around this restriction and this is a
bit of an odd one so instead of just a
normal
sort of just like out trying to invoke
the alert function directly what we can
do is we can take a string and we can
take the constructor of the string which
is the string constructor and we can
take the constructor of the string
constructor which is the function
constructor and we take the function
constructor and we can provide it with a
new function as text and then we can
invoke that function this is this was a
bypass of the sandbox that was in
angular so if I send this in I'm gonna
get this annoying pop-up and it's gonna
pop up twice for some reason this was a
way to get around this restriction and
the interesting bit that you can see
here is if we look all the way down here
we can actually see that this is HTML
escaped so the server-side framework try
to do the right thing and and kind of
escape things or you're not supposed to
be able to go in and out of JavaScript
and things like that but before angular
sees this code it's going to be D
escaped by the HTML parser because it's
gonna say okay there's this this text
inside this this element and I'm just
gonna take that out I'm gonna I'm gonna
give it to angular and angular sees a
there's a template cool I'm gonna I'm
gonna execute it so here's an example of
angular injection from Rockstar Games
it's got a bounty of thousand dollars in
this case and it was rated as high so
example of the same thing that I just
showed you so if we want to test for
template injection you can try all kinds
of templates so if you know what kind of
framework you're using you can try to
inject templates that work for that
specific framework so either a double or
a triple curly braces it could be like a
dollar and then curly braces it could be
all kinds of things thatthat specific
and I usually test with things like two
times two or four minus one and things
like that because that will easily show
if something is working or not I will
see what I get back and if it's the same
thing then it's probably safe but
sometimes it doesn't render the template
exactly where you are but when you're
clicking around you might find that at
some point later it does actually render
it because they're like
being outside of the component or
something like that so we can use this
for for a cross-site scripting like I
just showed you but and we can also use
it to get remote code execution and and
run stuff on the server if we're gonna
stop template injection we have to make
sure that we don't double evaluate in
place so we don't check the contents of
one template render that and then we put
that into a second template and then
like string concatenation thing and then
create another template from that and
then run that all over again and then
when we have these because we're using
client-side templates we have to make
sure that the server doesn't give the
browser a template that is not intended
to do and this was actually in the
angular documentation for a long time do
not mix client and server templates it
says at the top point here in in the
last versions of angular they actually
removed this sound box altogether
because there was a group of researchers
that we're trying all the time to break
out of the sandbox so whenever angular
patched the sound box they would go back
in and find a new way to bypass the
sound box so at some point they just
said we're not gonna have this sound box
anymore because it doesn't make sense
you shouldn't mix client and server
templates anyway so we're we're gonna
just remove the the sound box altogether
so then you could actually have done
alert one if that was the thing that you
want to do the next thing is insecure
course or a cross origin resource
sharing this is also something that
we've seen a lot during the last years a
lot of developers seem to kind of miss
understand what this header is doing or
they kind of forget that they deployed
something that was really permissive and
it ends up in production even though it
was just meant for test but so we have
these headers that will allow the
browser to read stuff if if it's just
correctly so I asked my friend Google
Translate to help me understand what
this header is doing so we have as the
first example here access control allow
origin example comm access control allow
credentials true I'm gonna translate
that from HTTP to English and it's gonna
say ok so if the user is logged in and
this it's example.com please allow that
site to access to users data okay so we
really have to try
example to come in this case if we want
that to work what happens then if I do
access control allow origin star and
then access control allow region and
translate that and it's gonna say well
if the user is logged in please
allow any site that the user visits to
access the users data huh that doesn't
sound good
luckily the browser vendors knew we were
going to mess up this one so you're not
actually allowed to have the policy that
says access control allow region star
and then allow credentials true so this
is this is what you'd see in the in the
browser console in chrome for instance
it's gonna say well this this is not
allowed sorry you can't do that but as
developers we are creative so we've
found ways to mess this off anyway so
the common mistakes the echo that's the
first one so you can't have star so
people figure that well I can just take
the originator coming into the server
and I can add that I as the access
control allow Origin header going back
as the response header and it will work
yeah you now re-enabled access
controller our edge in star you really
shouldn't have done that and this is
something we've seen a lot the next one
insufficient validation so origin
requests get origin header and if origin
ends with example.com then we're going
to add this so we're not going to add
just any header but if it if it ends
with example to come that's fine except
not example.com also ends with
example.com but it's not example.com
third one is no what is no well access
control allow origin no access control
allow credentials true no we have to ask
Google Translate again about this one so
access control allow regional a
translate that and Google Translate says
well if the user is logged in please
allow any site the user visits to access
the users data as long as the sites
knows how to use iframe with the sandbox
attribute okay here's an example so we
have an iframe with the sandbox we say
allow scripts allow forms
and then in this iframe we do this
request to the server this xhr request
in this case it's going to get the null
origin as its origin and so we've kind
of once again we added this allow origin
star allow credentials true a lot of
this stuff was found by a guy called
James Kelly and James kettle works for
ports wigger which creates the burps
burps wit which is one of the the best
pen testing tools that for for web
applications and and this is one of the
bugs that he reported and as you can see
this was reported to tomato and down
here we see the exact pattern that I
just showed you for one of them it will
allow anything ending in some tomato
comm including not tomato comm so this
was the exact same example next one
server site request forgery
what is server so we you might have
heard of client-side request forgery
what is server-side request forgery well
a server-side request might be a reverse
proxy it might be something in our
system that once we send in a request to
do something that system is going to do
another request to get something else so
we might do an HTTP request to some kind
of system which might be a server
application might be a nginx it might be
some other type of reverse proxy it
might be whatever and then based on that
request the server application will lend
us a second HTTP request to get some
data somewhere else so this might be
from a micro service it might be from
some service out on the Internet it
might be something completely different
well anyway the thing the thing that
where this can be a problem is if in the
first request we can modify the location
of the second request so here's a simple
example so we have a request from the
browser that comes in and it's
example.org slash images slash 200 by
200 slash product dot JPEG and in our
server application what we're doing is
we're taking the original URL and with
extracting the we're removing the first
part and we're putting in a new server
which is HTTP images stuff example.org
instead
and then we're going to get that I'm
going to strain that back to the
end-user
so we're deleting the first part adding
something new and then we're going to
grab that data and string it back to
user the problem in this case is what if
we do something like this well it's
going to delete the first part and it's
eventually then going to go to images of
example.org adat evil comm so by
modifying the first request we can now
specify a new location for the
back-channel request so this is server
side request forgery
we can now make the server do a request
that it didn't intend to do so there are
many ways of doing this and this is
another example instead of instead of
just specifying a domain name we could
specify an IP in this case we do this
will become basically basic off so it
becomes the the first part images dot
example.org becomes the username dummy
becomes the password and an act and then
the IP that we actually want to go to
that's another trick that some people do
some some systems they have this thing
where they want to import data for us so
this might be like an RSS feed but it
could also be like financial data or
something so we can have an XML file
someone somewhere on our site and we can
make that their system go and read that
data for us so this would be a typical
example where we could see and something
that would load something that wasn't
supposed to load so it could do
something like this instead so instead
of going out and grabbing the data that
it was intended
we're gonna go to localhost and we're
going to go to the MongoDB database that
sits on local host on port 220 7017
I'm gonna read data off of that is that
because we can now make requests
wherever we want or in some cases we
could even use abuse this to read files
like we did with xxe so we could use a
file URL it would go read the file
instead of going to an external URL but
where this has become very interesting
is in cloud providers because a lot of
cloud providers they have this host at
160 9.25 469 dot to 54 which is called a
method of the host and this is a place
where you can go to get information
about the current cloud server but you
can also get in in ABS you can also get
security credentials so we could use
this to get security credentials back to
us then we might be able to SSH into the
server and of course we could access all
kinds of other systems there as well and
this is hard like protecting against
this is really hard like let's look at
IP addresses for instance this is from
from the slides of guy called Nicaragua
a French man who's been doing a lot of
research into this so let's let's okay
so we have 169.254 hundred sixty 9.25
for this is the same IP four to five hey
that that's that's above 256 what's
going on well a lot of frameworks they
were just like you mod 256 if the number
is too high so this is the same IP with
overflow this is the same IP just
numeric this is the same IP with or
numeric forum with overflow this is the
same IP in hex format this is the same
IP in hex format without the dots
this is overflow in hex format without
dots this is octal IP so in instead of
this in the 10 number 10 system or 16
system we are in hex we're now using 8
based on it so there are all kinds of
formats this is the same thing it's
octal mode but in this case we have
overflow or a lot of zeros so this can
be quite confusing if we're trying to
parse this correctly we could also use
the main name so we could create our own
domain name custom evil.com and we could
point that at 127 0 0 1 so it looks ok
well even calm doesn't look ok but if it
looked like a bit lip a little bit more
benign than that so the server would try
and will resolve that and we get oh I'm
going to go localhost thing and I
grabbed some stuff out of there
so someone actually set up a service for
this so if you do 127.0.0.1 that's sip
dot IO that's going to resolve to the IP
in front and you can base 36 encoded as
well so in this case it still resolves
to 100 and
seven zero zero one and we can add stuff
in front of that as well to make it even
more convoluted so 0.0.0.0 that's like
all interfaces it doesn't have to be a
hundred and twenty seven series or one
either it can be one hundred twenty
seven four times it will be the same
thing and of course in in ipv6 we get
all these kinds of new things like a
different format for localhost to get
yeah you can see them here so there are
all kinds of ways of specifying the same
IP and blacklisting this can be quite
hard and then there's a guy called
orange psy who's been doing a lot of
research lately into like URL parsers
and he found that like this URL here it
would be parsed differently depending on
if it was parsed on Windows or Linux so
on Windows it would see the whole thing
as one path but in Linux did we see the
first part as the file and then what
comes after the question mark would just
be disregarded and of course there's
apache tomcat which is quite common in
the java world which for some reason
lets you specify dot dot semicolon and
it would treat that as what slash dot
dot slash because why not so you could
use this to do path reversal and get
access to things that you're not
supposed to be able to access so here's
an example of a s srf server-side
request 43 once again from hacker 1 in
this case if we see all the way down
here that's the exact same IP that I
just showed you like 169.254 169.254
it's a perfect example of of that a AWS
IP some of the cloud vendors they they
now require that in order to be able to
reach that host you have to specify a
custom header and that's supposed to
protect against this thing because then
you wouldn't necessarily be able to add
a custom header when you're doing a
necessary effort ACK how can we detect
that this thing is going on well we
could do something as ever as building a
log so we know whenever we have
a
a web client or some kind of outbound
requests we could log all of those so
just like we have an access log for
inbound requests we could also have an
egress log for outbound requests so we
and we could search that from time to
time and see if if something bad shows
up or we could have like a whitelist or
something in there so another way of
protecting us this is we could use an
outgoing proxies instead of doing all
the requests from our server which sits
in a maybe in a network zone with access
to a lot of things we could say well if
you're ever going to do an outbound
requests well gonna do this in a
different network zone where there's
only this proxy server and it can only
go outside we should of course normalize
the hostname so we could resolve it to
an IP and then we could either use
firewall rules or some other way of
doing a whitelist or blacklist based
approach there so IP tables or something
like that next one is something called
subdomain takeover this is a guy called
fronts percent of detective I he did a
big write-up of this but this is there's
been a lot of these lately I'm gonna
show you a quite recent example of this
so what this does it exploits that we
sometimes configure DNS to point to
places and we forget that we did that at
some point and then someone else can
take over one of our subdomains so for
instance in in Heroku we can specify our
name as a part of the URL for the
program in in AWS we can also have our
name as a part of the URL but it's still
like an Amazon domain like that this is
the top-level domain and may so maybe
we've set up a DNS entry to point to one
of these and then at some point we just
remove them and we forget all about it
so detective ID they found that there
were over a hundred different cloud
services that have these kinds of
options where you could specify your own
domain as a part of this so let's see an
example here so let's say OS dot and
Heroku app calm so the company that owns
this thing they're gonna go in and say
well this Heroku app is going to have a
custom domain name which is going to be
always thought example to come because
that's our company domain top-level
domain example to come
and then we go into your DNS and we say
that if you get the IP of or you get a
lookup for OS dot example to come then
you're gonna go to this roki DNS thing
instead so to show it as an animation
instead so we're gonna go out and you
say hey I want to I want to know the IP
of example.com and it's going to go to
the DNS of example.com which is gonna
say hey you should you should go over at
Heroku Danis and ask them instead so you
go over there and you get an IP back and
then you can go and reach the actual
service running on Heroku and everything
works fine but then at some point we
remove this rope application but we
forget to fix the DNS so the attacker
can now go in and recreate an
application with the exact same name and
they can now own our subdomain because
in our DNS we still point to this thing
even though we removed it so this can
have quite a big impact like if an
attacker can control one over subdomains
this is perfect for fishing now you
actually have a domain that's belongs to
the company that you're trying to fish
you could use this to inject cookies to
my domain white cookies you could do
defacements and all kinds of things like
that and you could even create HTTPS
certificates for this subdomain so
here's one example a subdomain takeover
on s3 at Shopify com
here's the very recent example Microsoft
had this domain that they were using for
Windows tiles so this is from this is
this is a it's quite recent April 17 and
they they forgot about this domain are
they they forgot that they had DNS entry
pointing to a natural service so the
host that should deliver the XML files
notification dot build my pinned site
come only showed an error message from
Microsoft cloud service assure the host
was redirected to a subdomain of a
Shusher
however this subdomain wasn't registered
with a sure so a guy called Hanna Burke
he went in and he registered that domain
and now he kind of controlled this thing
that was used to display data on tiles
in Windows which is kind of serious but
he did it to block it and then reported
it to Microsoft
here's another example it's a bit that
the the text is a bit small but what it
says here is this is from cert SH where
you can look up in the certificate
transparency logs like certificates that
have been issued by the CAS and in this
case a certificate was issued with the
domain name Simon gris-gris has hacked
prod to do bird calm because he was able
to do to domain subdomain takeover for
one for prod to over comm and then he
used some custom domain service here and
created a certificate for the thing that
he hacked but he added like this
I have hacked it calm to the beginning
and this is gonna stay there forever
because the transparency log is gonna Sh
it has to show all the certificates
that's ever been issued so if you go and
search it will find it
the next thing I'm gonna show you is
something called web cache poisoning and
this was also something that James
kettle which I mentioned earlier found
when he was doing some research he was
looking into bugs that were hard to
exploit so maybe you could as a user you
could send something in and you would
get it back but you couldn't get any
other users to see it so if you maybe
you could like to our self XSS self
across at scripting attack but you
couldn't get any other users to see the
the stuff that was injected so you could
basically only attack yourself which is
which is kind of annoying if you're
trying to do cross-site scripting attack
so he was looking at this and he was
trying to exploit these unexploited bugs
and he has written a blog post about
this and presented at a black after a
few years ago so let's look at how this
works so we have our server we have a
proxy that sits in front of it
this might be our own proxied might
could have been something like
CloudFlare or some other type of proxy
that sits in between and then we have
our clients so the first client comes in
he asked for some website it's not in
the cache so the cache goes back in it
goes to the server and looks up the data
store sit in the cache and returns it to
the client so when the next client comes
along and asks there's going to be hid
in the cache
the data is gonna go back so everything
works as this is how a cache is supposed
to work but then what if the attacker is
able to call this URL with this attack
then have this go to the server and the
server has some vulnerability in this
case so the attacker sends some
malicious data into the server the
server does something stupid with it a
render systems in a way that maybe
becomes a cross-site scripting attack
and then that's stored in the cache so
when a benign client comes along later
this client is going to get the poisoned
version the one with the attack in isn't
the this is what what James kettle was
researching and he found a lot of ways
to do this because of frameworks because
of car caches works and things like that
so in this case I have at the top here I
have a simple request that I can do it
only has two headers in this case it has
the get slash HTTP 1 1 and specify the
host header as well so if I send this in
I get back 200 ok and I get this URL
here this is the important part in this
case so you can see it says dub dub dub
hackable dot Network here and that's the
same thing as or that's that the host of
the actual server in this case so if we
go over here instead it says attacker
comm and it says X forwarded host so
this is a new header and if I now I'm
the attacker I'm gonna try to poison the
cache so if I send this in we now see
that this thing was changed so it now it
doesn't say dub dub dub dot detectable
Network anymore it says attacker.com
there instead but our benign client
still sees the the benign version but we
poison something with the URL parameter
so we poisoned a cache that wasn't the
same that the benign client was asking
for so we remove this and we try to send
it in and now you can see down here it
says it still says dub dub dub dub
hackable Network so I'm going to send
this in a few times because we have to
wait until the cache expires and at some
point if you look down there you're
gonna see at some point is going to
change this is when the cache expired
you
that it expired so now if I go back here
and I send this request you can now see
that the benign client also got this
poisoned version how brave are you guys
are you brave enough to participate if
you are you can go through this URL I'm
not going to do anything harmful so if
you have a phone or a laptop you can go
to this URL here if you open it you can
open it in a new tab here it will see
yeah it will look something like this
right so it's dub dub dub hackable dot
network it should look something like
this you should say welcome and then it
should be a big NDC Minnesota link or a
picture there you see it yeah now I'm
gonna try it to poison it so all I'm
doing now is the web server
or not the web server the browser is now
hammering this thing it's hammering this
thing with requests I'm not changing
anything on the server if you try to
reload the page in your brain in your
browser now you should see something
different so I didn't change the server
at all I only poisoned the cache so it
should now look something like this
instead so that's cache poisoning and
it's quite a it can be quite a bad
problem if we have this so these are
some of the headers that James Kelly
James kettle identified by X host x4
with the toast X original URL and X
rewrite URL so these would be used by
frameworks in ways that they were they
shouldn't and we could use this to
poison different URLs and he has some
some really cool example applications
that you can try if you go to his blog
and read on his write-up on this it can
be hard to do this attack correctly
because we have to figure out which URL
parameters are part of the cache keys
and things like that and which headers
are part of the cache keys but James
Kelly working for burps whit he added a
new extension the burp suite called para
minor which can kind of automate this
stuff so if we want to stop it ourselves
we should probably block these headers
if we're coming in from the outside like
X
host exhausts alright for using them
that is we should stop them from coming
in because they're not supposed to come
from the outside they're supposed to be
added by this proxy one of the things
that that James kettle suggests were
also to add these headers as a part of
the cache key because if we add them to
the part of the cache key then the
benign clein is never going to send
those headers and so the client is never
going to get the poison version we
should of course also fixed the server
side application which in this case
allowed us to inject a bad code on the
server based on a host header yeah I
have a couple of more minutes I'm going
to show you one last thing that I
discovered recently it's something
called where we're going to look at data
API so how many of you are familiar with
graph QL but a few of you yeah so graph
QL it says graph queue is a query
language for API is and a runtime for
filling those queries with your existing
data so we can now create like these
magic rest endpoints with where we can
query and get all kinds of data instead
of having to specify every message and
this is really cool as a developer
because we can now we don't have to
specify all the endpoints and we can we
can get the data at the exact data we
need etc etc but if we're not doing this
correctly we might also end up with data
leakage authorization issues things like
that so this is actually real stuff and
this is not a graph zero but the first
one here is I saw this once when I do it
what we're doing is a security test
script ASP query and then the SQL query
so this is SQL injection by design and
same thing this was a web service where
they would take an SQL query as a part
of the soap message and then execute
that and return the result back this is
the kind of stuff that we can end up
with if we're doing graphic UL the wrong
way because we can we can be able to
access things that we're not supposed to
be at to access we can get access to
data that's belongs to other users and
all kinds of stuff like that a couple of
example this was from from hacker 1 and
if this was actually on hacker 1 so it
wasn't just a program
hacker one but it was hacker hacker one
that was hacked in this in this and this
finding here and so they have this issue
where by using graph QL you could go you
could traverse some links between
objects and then you were able to grab
data but a better one that I found the
other day was this one verified on
Shopify cloud comm graph QL discloses
internal bear consumption and one of the
comments said if you can escalate this
to bear denial of service that would be
devastating yeah so this is a bunch of
links I'll tweet these out later so you
don't have to photograph them you can
get them in a format where you can
actually click them but a lot of people
have been doing a lot of research into
this I'm I'm merely the conveyor of this
information like there's a couple of
guys who made something called Y so
serials which is a lot of listings of
fun abilities in terms of these
realization attacks you have XSLT stuff
like in here you have the template
injection once again that's James James
Carroll behind that you have the links
to the subdomain takeover stuff you have
the links to this to Nicaragua grass
presentation our own on SSR F and some
YouTube videos that Sarah and things
like that so that's it there is a URL at
the bottom here if you want to play with
some of the demo stuff that I just
showed you like X sexy and insecure
digitalisation there is a github repo
there
it's github.com slash of the doll slash
deserialize and you can get that app
running as a docker container and you
and and nero in the github repo you can
also see like the the payloads that you
can send it to attack so that's pretty
well on time so thanks a lot for coming
[Applause]